the twice differentiable function G and
its second derivative G prime prime our
graph and you can see it right over here
I'm actually working off of the article
on Khan Academy called justifying using
second derivatives so we see our
function G and we see not its first
derivative but its second derivative
here in this brown color so then the
article goes on to say or the problem
goes on to say for students were asked
to give an appropriate calculus based
justification for the fact that G has an
inflection point at x equals negative 2
so let's just feel good that it at least
intuitively feels right so x equals
negative 2 remember what an inflection
point is it's where we're going from
concave downwards to concave upwards or
concave upwards to concave downwards or
another way to think about it it's a
situation where our slope goes from
decreasing to increasing or from
increasing to decreasing and when we
look at it over here it looks like look
how it looks like our slope is
decreasing it's positive but it's
decreasing goes to 0 then it keeps
decreasing it becomes it's negative now
keep decreasing until we get to about x
equals negative 2 and then it seems that
it's increasing it's getting less and
less and less and less negative it looks
like it's a zero right over here then it
just keeps increasing gets more and more
and more positive so it does indeed look
like at x equals negative 2 we go from
being concave downwards to concave
upwards now a calculus based
justification is we could look at it at
the second derivative and see where the
second derivative crosses the x axis
because where the second derivative is
negative that means our slope is
decreasing we are concave downwards and
where the second derivative is positive
it means our first derivative is
increasing our slope of our original
function is increasing and we're concave
upwards so notice we do indeed the
second derivative does indeed cross the
x-axis at x equals negative 2 it's not
enough for it to just be zero or touch
the x-axis it needs to cross the x axis
in order for us to have an inflection
point there so given that let's look at
the students justifications and see what
we can if we kind of put and play that
put the teach
had in our mind and say what a teacher
would say for the different
justifications so the first student says
the second derivative of G changes signs
at x equals negative 2 well that's
exactly what we were just talking about
if the second derivative changes signs
goes in this case it goes from negative
to positive that means our first
derivative went from decreasing to
increasing which is indeed good for
saying this is a calculus based
justification so at least for now I'm
gonna put kudos you are correct there it
crosses the x-axis so this is ambiguous
what what is crossing the x-axis if a
student wrote this I'd say what are they
talking about the function are they
talking about the first derivative the
second derivative and so I would say
please use more precise language this
cannot be accepted as a correct
justification all right let's do the
other ones the second derivative of G is
increasing at x equals negative 2 well
no that doesn't justify why you have an
inflection point there for example the
second derivative is increasing at x
equals negative 2 point 5 the second
derivative is even increasing at x
equals negative 1 but you don't have
inflection points at those places so I
would say this doesn't justify why G has
an inflection point and then the last
student responds the graph of G changes
concavity at x equals negative 2 that is
true but that isn't a calculus based
justification we'd want to use our
second derivative here